[音楽]
ん
持った
[音楽]
バジャー
外れ社長で動く園は東京で仕事にいるんですけども
五大いらしてるんですよツアーイライラしてるんです人は入ってるだけでいいこと
ばっかりではなく絶対嫌なことも起きますそれはどう発散することが大事なんですけど
も
僕に発射するつありませんママに相談するくらいてぐらいですねその嫌なこととか1
切れた妹に8本
10月嫌なこと凄いあったんですよ実はみんなそれを発散するためには桜がにして皆に
聴いてもらおうかなと思えね
いやのましたごめんねよして+もう叫べば何がストレス発散になるんじゃないかなと
思いますね
社長の10月にあった嫌な事まと
ね今日は発表していきたいとおもいます結構胸クソなことが多かったと10月合うなん
ならメモしましたからねはいはいありましたありましたありましたもうなんか毎月
作ろうからこういうのがよくあるじゃないすかなんか病型ユーチューバーでさあ
10月のお気に入りコスメみたいなそんな感じで10月の初め者沿いかに聞いて
くださいどうぞ
まずあったのはですね僕夜中に後輩たちと映画見に
たんですよの映画館で上映の端までも5分前ですよもうすぐもうすぐ始まるたときに
女の子女子中学生ぐらいどこかな1人来ててなんかその日けっこう人が多くて人多い
とき写真お断りするんですよ私もとりあえずの僕も取れるんだって人がたくさん来るん
で届い時はどんな人でも子供でも誰でもちょっと photo by していただい
てるんですけどもその映画が始まる5分前にや
矢部急ぎすげーって友達と映画化に向かっている時に増資中学生の一人の女のほうがの
僕に話しかけてきたんですよ
肇社長ですかはいそうですと出会いいつも応援してます
あの様方が写真撮ってもいいですか勁戰もうなんかもうすぐ始まっちゃってって言っ
たらその女子中学生の後ろにいた母親が
いやいいいいいいいいいいがとって撮って撮って
いいああ娘のためなら何でもするその姿勢はいいと思うんですけどもいい
よくないよくないよくないマジで腹たちましたね娘のためならと思って言ってるのは
いいと思うんですけども他の人への配慮が足りないゾーマあなたが何がいいなんだろう
何がいいのか分からマジでよくねえは映画はず
抹茶その一人で是非お断りしてるんでその子だけ取っちゃっても不平等みたいになっ
ちゃうんで僕はもう断固として断りたかったんですけどもそんな母親です ae で
降りだしなあこれも話通じねーなーと思ってその pot だけ取っちゃったんです
けどちょっとイラッとしましたねー
良い一なんだなぁイラッとしたなう
叫びます o air
で砕けないクラー
はい次いきますあの僕コンビニよく使っててなんかこれいうの初めてなんですけどもが
慰問した時のお釣り絶対全部募金してるんですよ最終が音がなるの嫌なんでをサクラ
サクに回収するんですけども保全にノー釣り実は全部冒険ばを入れててあー全然人とか
じゃないですよ想いだけなんで写りまだ手間が省けるですよね釣り渡すのでちょっと
時間かかるんで当たりそっちでって言ったらすぐ入れてくれるとすごいか
李がスムーズになるんでね色々と小銭を募金するの結構メリットがあるんですけども
50円のお菓子買うときに1000円出しても僕950円募金するんです基本的に
どんなに高い曲でも僕絶対募金するんで近くのコンビニはわかってるんですよ近くの
コミュにわかってるですの買った物より高い金額を募金しているのが当たり前だっても
覚えられてるんでリズムいいんですけども
東京とか普段行かないコンビニそれ
やると店員さんがめっちゃ驚くんですけど1000円以てミクまんかいます
890内のお返しです入った瞬間にあってそこで大丈夫でって言ったら店員さんが
えっ
八部激鬱良いんですよお客ら890円ですよええ
みたいな風さあ
消していった何がそんなダメだの何がそんな不思議なの募金することのカットもの以上
の金額が募金者が不思議
おかしいかなぜんぜんわかり驚くのはばかり驚くなわかるからさ
えっありがとうございますぐらいで止めておけばいいのにもうなんかほとんどのデータ
をはぺ基準ですよ
また草全くばかげ基準ですよ待ってます
て語録コメントぐらいその動作にして反応するんですよいいじゃんぼ木苗しても時間が
もったいねーかボケしてんな
ですね何か急いでるからそういうことしてんのに逆にすることによって時間とられる
ことによるイライラがすごかったです
叫びます心配してくれてありがとう
これはですねちょっと大事な話なんですけども僕ん家っても特定されてるんですよね
全然近くに来てくださることに頭いいんですよもうバレてるんでどうしようもないと
思うんでただ僕が危惧しているのはそれによって地域の住民の皆様に迷惑を掛けるのが
一番嫌なんですよなんで畑下も含め僕も近くで写真撮るの全員 ng にしてるんです
よ
なぜかというとと出るってバカ
するとそれを聞いてたくさんの人が来ちゃうからとてもありがたいことですありがとう
ございます何で基本的に僕んちの近くで僕にあっても僕すごい
趙紫陽対応なんでそこだけは許してくださいなんでコミュニティの写真とかもとらない
してなんか何もしないしそれはねなんか太陽よかったら
始めつつ出るのって言って人がたくさん来るかもしれないんで女僕もいいですよホンダ
僕の写真とか撮ってあげないです
を色々してあげたいんですけどそれをスタート人が止まんなくなって地域の人に迷惑
かかるのが同会長は嫌なんで別に来てもいいけどなんか写真目的とかでマジで来て
欲しくないんですけどもそれをなぁ
なんか肇社長に会ったら使用太陽だったとか
写真も撮ってくんなかったとかなんで写真すらもとってくれないのとかマジでうぜーと
か言う人いたんです
いやー
[音楽]
あのもちろん結構冷たい人間なんですけどもさすがに応援してくださる方には感謝し
てるし好きなんで僕は色々してあげたいんですけども素晴らしい環境で僕は動画査定を
させていただいてるんですね僕は周りの人たちもすごい大事なんでその人たちに迷惑を
かけることだけは絶対したくないんでそういう対応させていただいてるんですけども
もうなんかには一生のお願いです写真撮ってくださいって言うと思いましたではこんな
とこで一生の
音が使うな全然場所もバレてるんでくる分にはいいんですけども来ても僕たちは何もし
ませんするとイベント会場みたいに人が来ちゃうようになるかもしれないんでもう例外
なしで全員塩対応とさせていただいておりますすみません周りの人たちのためです叫び
ます俺を着てくれてありがとう
me
[音楽]